if we are in a pretty relaxed state or
if we are happy we generally feel like
we can do what we want to do we can
maneuver through our environment we can
make choices that are reasonable but
oftentimes we're not in relaxed and
happy States that's just part of The
Human Experience obviously and there is
a fundamental feature to the nervous
system which is this thing they call the
autonomic nervous system which is just
fancy nerd speak for the components of
your nervous system that raise your
levels of alertness or bring them way
down sometimes we hear fight or flight
rest and digest but basically what
happens is when we are at the extremes
of the autonomic what I call seesaw of
very very alert to the point of being
really stressed or panicked or concerned
or if we are very close to sleep and
we're drowsy and we're exhausted at
those points along the autonomic nervous
system our thoughts become a bit like a
runaway train you know if you're very
upset it's hard to talk yourself out of
it if you're stressed it's hard to think
yourself out of it in fact you can start
doing all sorts of third personing and
rationalization you can call someone you
can text somebody very hard to get
yourself out of those states with
thinking alone but the beauty of the
autonomic nervous system is that it
traverses the brain and the body and it
connects to all the organs of the body
and it's a two-way street such that
certain behaviors even in certain
patterns of breathing allow us to shift
where we are on the autonomic Continuum
between very very alert and stressed and
very calm and thereby give our mind a
shift also in terms of the kinds of
thoughts that we can entertain the sorts
of actions that we can engage in need
motivation watch top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today the song from one of the best Dr
Andrew huberman and my take on his top
ten or it's a success enjoy
to make this concrete if you're very
very stressed you're very upset
two things happen one it's very hard to
take your focus off whatever it is
that's upsetting you and if you don't
know what's upsetting you you know pure
anxiety but you don't know why it's very
hard to take your mind off of the
feelings of anxiety
in those states of mind there's another
component which is that for whatever
reason and no one really understands why
this is it feels as if the state that
you're in will go on forever now when
we're in happy relaxed States rarely do
we think gosh this is going to go on
forever and yet when we are in these
unfortunate states of mine we get the
idea somehow it sort of hijacks our
perception of time and we feel like this
is never going to stop
if we turn to the body and certain
behaviors let me talk about what those
are we are able to move ourselves along
the autonomic Continuum and at that
point when we've done that successfully
it's actually quite straightforward to
do we are able to think about things
differently we start to get a sense that
the way we feel might not be the way
we're going to feel forever and it's in
those shifts that we start to realize ah
my mind actually is not my best friend
at these extremes but there's a lot more
to it you're only getting the tip of the
iceberg in those States so that's why I
say if you can't control the mind with
the Mind look to the body to control the
Mind rule number two regulate dopamine
levels when you deprive a kid of
something that
is very very dopaminergic that
stimulates the release of a lot of
dopamine
and then they actually have access to
that at a friend's house or something of
that sort it is going to create a
massive increase in pleasure
so I think there's this issue about you
know not eliminating things but
having a controlled relationship to
these
very very powerful stimuli I mean you
know movies are very powerful
um you know this is not the topic that
we're talking about right now but you
know I get a lot of questions these days
about dopamine and about pornography for
instance pornography you know removing
all judgment from this because that's
not what the basis of the conversation
is pornography has created an enormous
number of problems for in certain
countries in the in the last 10 years
mostly because of its immense
availability and the intensity of the
images it's also wired up a lot of young
brains to become aroused watching other
people have sex as opposed to being in
the physical act of sex themselves so
there's a lot of like you can't even
call it third personing they're not you
know they're aroused by imagery that
they're not actually participating in
this is and I hear a lot about I get a
lot of questions about this especially
from the younger audience so
um am I saying all pornography is bad no
not necessarily I you know I don't know
any discussion about uh sex and
sexuality I always say we're of course
framing it in the context of
age-appropriate consensual context
appropriate species appropriate so but
the point is that you know anything that
stimulates a lot of dopamine release is
a very sharp blade so if you eliminate
it completely great in the short term
potentially treacherous in in the long
term that kid goes to a friend's house
and sees you know a movie let's let's
just remove pornography from the
conversation cookies yeah it's something
that tastes candy for the first time and
the brain is hardwired to get very very
excited about that so then you now
you're dealing with a kid that
potentially could get even more addicted
to these things so it just has to be
controlled it has to be controlled any
potent stimulus highly processed highly
palatable food
um visual imagery movies
um has to be controlled rule number
three get rid of obsessions if we were
to draw a line between the obsessions
and the compulsions that line could be
described as anxiety
now we need to Define what anxiety is
and to be quite honest most of
psychology and science can't agree on
exactly what anxiety is typically the
way we think about fear is that it's a
heightened state of autonomic arousal so
increased heart rate increase breathing
sweating Etc in response to an immediate
and present threat or perceived threat
whereas anxiety generally speaking in
the scientific literature relates to the
same sorts of thought patterns and
somatic bodily responses heart rate
breathing Etc but without a clear and
present danger being in the environment
or right there so that's the way that
we're going to talk about anxiety now
and anxiety is really what binds the
obsessions and compulsions such that
someone will have an intrusive thought
so for instance someone will have the
thought that if they turn left on any
street that something bad will happen
Okay that's an obsession it's actually
not all that uncommon now how bad and
what the specificity of that bad thing
really is will vary some some people
will think if I turn left something
generally bad will happen it just makes
me feel anxious so they always insist on
going right whereas other people will
think if I turn left
so and so will die or I will die or
something terrible will happen I'll get
a disease or someone else will get a
disease or I'll be cursing myself or
somebody else in some very specific way
this is unfortunately quite common in
people with OCD so
they have this feeling and the feeling
can be generally or specifically related
to a particular outcome but beneath that
is a feeling of anxiety a quickening of
the heartbeat a quickening of breathing
a narrowing of one's visual Focus I've
talked about this before on other
podcasts the master stress and other
podcasts but if you haven't heard those
let me just briefly describe that when
we are in a state of increased so-called
autonomic arousal alertness stress Etc
our visual field literally Narrows the
aperture of our visual field gets
smaller and that's because of the
relationship between the autonomic
nervous system and your visual system so
you start seeing the world through sort
of soda straw view or through
binocular-like view as opposed to seeing
the big picture why is that important
well it literally sharpens and narrows
your focus toward the very thing that
the obsessions and the compulsions are
focused on so the person walking down
the street who sees the opportunity to
go left or right will only see the bad
decision their visual field Narrows very
tightly along that possibility of taking
a left turn and I know as I described it
seems totally irrational but I want to
emphasize that the person with OCD knows
it's irrational they might feel crazy
because they're having these thoughts
but they know it makes no sense
whatsoever that left somehow would be
different than right in terms of
outcomes in this particular case and yet
it feels as if it would in fact in some
cases it feels as if they went left they
would have a full-blown panic attack so
the idea here is that the obsessions and
compulsions are bound by anxiety but
then by taking a right hand turn again
in this one particular example by taking
a right hand turn there's a very brief I
should mention very brief relief of that
anxiety
at the time of the decision to go right
not left and there's an additional drop
in anxiety while one takes the right
hand turn as opposed to the left-hand
turn and then as I alluded to before
there's a reinforcement of the
compulsion in other words by going right
it doesn't create a situation in the
brain and psychology of the person that
uh you know what I'm not anxious anymore
left would have probably been okay it
reinforces the idea that right made me
feel better or turning right made me
feel better and going left would have
been that much worse again it reinforces
the obsession even further and again we
could swap out right turns and left
turns with something like hand washing
the feeling that something is
contaminated and the need to wash one's
hands even though one already washed
their hands 20 30 50 times prior we're
actually going to go back to that
example a little bit later when we talk
about one particular category of
therapies that are very effective in
many people for OCD which are the
cognitive behavioral and exposure
therapies so I think some of you have
heard of cognitive behavioral and
exposure therapies but the way they are
used to treat OCD is very much different
than the way they're used to treat other
sorts of anxiety disorders and other
sorts of disorders generally so it's
fair to say that up to 70 percent of
people with OCD have some sort of
anxiety or elevated anxiety either
directly related to the OCD or
indirectly related to the OCD and it's
really hard to tease those apart because
OCD can create its own anxiety as I
mentioned before it can even increase
its own anxiety and
there's also an issue of depression
having OCD can be very depressing right
especially if some of these OCD thoughts
and behaviors start to really impede
people's ability to function in life at
work in school and relationship they can
start feeling less optimistic about life
and in fact some people can become
suicidally depressed that's how bad OCD
can be for us so we have to be careful
when saying that 70 of people with OCD
also have anxiety or X number of people
with OCD are also depressed because we
don't know whether or not the depression
led the OCD or the other way around or
whether or not they're operating as we
say in science in parallel some of the
drug treatments for OCD and depression
and anxiety can tease some of that apart
and we'll talk about that but I think
it's fair to say that what binds the
obsessions and compulsions is anxiety
that there's a feeling of it or I should
say an urgent feeling of a need to get
rid of the obsession and the person
feels as if the only way they can do
that is to engage in a particular
compulsive Behavior Rule Number Four
balance social interactions when we lack
social interaction that we expect we
become pro-social
however
if we are chronically socially isolated
meaning we don't have interactions with
people for a long time we become
actually more introverted this is
separate from all of the tacky kind and
stuff that I talked about earlier or
falling into states of chronic stress
but it's well established now that in
humans and in animals
if you don't give them enough social
interaction they actually become
anti-social and so this is actually a
little bit like what one might see with
long-term fasting okay I give the
example of eating every four hours now
let's give the parallel example of
somebody who's been fasting perhaps for
two or three days if they are expecting
to eat and then the meal doesn't arrive
they are not necessarily going to
immediately try and seek out food and
that's a little bit counterintuitive you
would have thought well they haven't
eaten in a very long time they're going
to be very motivated to seek out food
but no they are accustomed to fasting
similarly the social homeostasis circuit
Works in a way such that when we don't
have social interactions for a very long
time we start to lose our craving for
social interactions also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the word worksheet designed specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number five
change your belief system if you give
people a little bit of an understanding
of the underlying mechanisms
it creates a system around any tool that
makes it easier to do that practice and
uh
makes it more impactful as well so what
I mean is you know I could do a whole
episode just listing off tools and
protocols for everything from Fat Loss
to focus and attention mental health
depression trauma grief Etc based on the
data but if I start each episode which I
do with a little bit of a of a
description of the mechanism for
instance how cold impacts metabolism
how for instance a particular childhood
attachment pattern to a parent
translates to an adult romantic
attachment pattern then when I go into
some of the description about the tools
My Hope Is that people will have those
mechanisms in mind or even just
subconsciously they're embedded and then
not only are they going to be more
willing to lean into those tools but
those tools will be more impactful and
the last thing I'll say about this is I
have a colleague at Stanford I should
introduce you guys because she'd make a
phenomenal podcast because her name is
Ali Crum Aaliyah crumb she is a tenure
professor at Stanford she's a trained
clinical psychologist she was a division
one gymnast and she's a martial artist
and she works on beliefs and belief
systems and she has incredible data
showing that
the result of anything you do or what
you eat
is both the consequence of that thing so
like she's done experiments for instance
where they give people milkshakes and
they tell them okay this is a low
calorie milkshake
or they tell people this is a high
calorie nutrient dense and it's a
regular milkshake it's a milkshake
people drink that and they measure
subjective reports of how fulfilling
that and how how much satiety how much
satisfaction it provides and for how
long and they measure hormones insulin
ghrelin all the hormones that are the
consequence of eating and what you find
is that if you think what they find is
that if people are told this is a high
calorie nutrient shake it provides much
more satisfaction for much longer than
if they're told that it's a low calorie
nutrient sparse shank and the hormones
that one secretes in response to that
milkshake differ in the two groups even
though the milkshakes are absolutely
identical because it's all about your
beliefs it's in part about your beliefs
because of course if you know uh you
can't tell yourself that the entire
chocolate cake is you know uh just a
bowl of broccoli and it's gonna have the
same effects as a bowl of broccoli so
anything you do whether or not it's
exercise cold bath what you consume is
the consequence of that thing there are
some undeniable non-negotiable realities
about your biology and then there's the
belief system and the other example I'll
give is they've done these beautiful
studies where they tell one group listen
stress is a part of life and it gives
you dementia it makes your thinking
suffer it can kill neurons it can do all
this terrible stuff they tell another
group
all that's true by the way in certain
contexts they tell another group
stress is a part of life but it can
sharpen your thinking it can bring out
your best it can stimulate your immune
system as long as it doesn't last too
long and what they find is that the
biological effects of stress on those
two groups match what those people are
taught about stress wow and so you can't
get around the realities of stress or
calories or things of that sort there's
the laws of physics but in the laws of
biology but belief systems have a
powerful role in how the tools and
practices that we engage in shape us and
so that's the The Logical backbone for
teaching people a bit about the
mechanism because if if I say hey do an
ice bath you know it increases your
metabolism increases your resilience and
can reduce pain and inflammation help
you sleep better at night great but lots
of people are saying that but if I say
listen there's this pathway where when
you get into cold water and it it's
really uncomfortable and you really want
to get out but you stay in for an extra
minute you stimulate this certain
adrenaline related pathway in your brain
and body now when you do it and you hit
that wall you're like I really want to
get out of here you think no I want to
stimulate that pathway and then your
belief and understanding about that
pathway really does shape the fact that
it works uh and so teaching mechanism is
in part for me about educating and
turning people on to the beauty of
biology but I realize look not everyone
wants to be a biologist or a researcher
but I think everybody wants better
mental health physical health and
performance and so mechanism has a real
impact rule number six shift your
perspective next I'd like to talk about
some of the research on and the roles of
hormones in OCD because it turns out to
be a very interesting relationship there
but before I do I want to point out
something that I realize I probably
should have said earlier which is one of
the key things for someone with OCD to
come to understand if they're going to
experience any relief of their symptoms
whether or not they're doing drug
treatments or behavioral treatments or
otherwise
is that thoughts are not as bad as
actions
right thoughts are not as bad as actions
one of the rules that people with OCD
seem to adopt for themselves is that
thoughts are really truly the equivalent
of actions so they'll have an intrusive
thought and we haven't spent too much
time on this today but earlier I touched
on the fact that some of the intrusive
thoughts that people have in OCD are
really disturbing they can be really
gross or at least gross to that person
they can evoke imagery that is you know
toxic or infectious or is
highly sexualized in a way that is
disturbing to them can be very taboo
this is not uncommon when you start
talking to people with OCD and you start
pulling on the thread again this would
be a psychiatrist who was trained to ask
the right questions and gain the comfort
and Trust of a patient they start to
reveal that these these thoughts are
really intrusive and kind of disturbing
which is why they feel so compelled to
try and suppress them with behaviors one
of the powerful elements of treatment
for OCD is to really support the patient
and make them realize that thoughts are
just thoughts and that everyone has
disturbing thoughts and then oftentimes
those disturbing thoughts Arise at the
most inconvenient and sometimes what
seems like the most inappropriate
circumstances and this relates to a
whole larger discussion that we could
have about what our thoughts and why do
they surface and how come when you stand
at the edge of a bridge even if you do
not want to jump off you think about
jumping off and you know this has to do
with the fact that your nervous system
as a prediction machine is oftentimes
testing possibilities and sometimes that
testing goes way off into the
Netherlands of the thought patterns and
emotional patterns that we all have
inside of us the big difference between
a thought and an action is that of
course the nervous system is one case
not translating those patterns of
thinking into motor sequences
that nerdy way of saying thoughts aren't
actions believe it or not can be helpful
for people if they really think about
that and use it as an opportunity to
realize that first of all they're not
crazy
they're not thinking and feeling this
stuff because they're bad or evil and of
course sometimes this can cross over
with other other elements of life where
we place moral judgment on people for
certain behaviors I think that's part of
a healthy Society of course that's why
we have laws and punishments and and
rewards for that matter for certain
types of behaviors but this idea that
thoughts are not as bad as actions and
that thoughts can be tolerated and the
anxiety around thoughts can be tolerated
and over time can diminish that's a very
powerful Hallmark theme of the treatment
of OCD so I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention it
thoughts are not actions actions can
harm us they can harm other people they
can soak up enormous amounts of time
thoughts can so soak up enormous amounts
of time they can be very troubling they
can be very detrimental we of course
want to be sensitive to that
but when it really comes down to it
the first step in treatment for OCD is
this realization where the approach to
the realization that thoughts are not as
bad as actions rule number seven learn
how your brain works people vary in the
extent to which they feel or have the
capacity to feel bonded to anyone and it
is now generally understood that some of
that variation might depend on
variations in oxytocin receptors or what
are called Gene polymorphisms for
oxytocin genes can have a number of
different sequences in them they're
nucleotide sequences we won't go into
genetics right now ages and G's and C's
and T's in various combinations are what
make up the genes genes are transcribed
into RNA RNA is translated into proteins
that affect cells okay the oxytocin Gene
encodes for oxytocin and variants in
that Gene change the amount and function
of oxytocin there's a really interesting
study published just this last year in a
relatively new Journal that journal has
a kind of an unusual name it's helion I
think it's helion and not helion but
helion
h-e-l-i-y-o-n this is a cell Press
Journal as far as I can tell it's a very
solid Journal certainly the cell press
label is very stringent and this paper
is entitled the relation between
oxytocin receptor Gene polymorphisms
which just means changes in in genes
or variations in genes adult attachment
and Instagram sociability and
exploratory analysis that's a really
wild study but I like the study it's
very thorough first author last name
carollo
c-a-r-o-l-l-o and what they found was
that by analyzing the genetics of
different individuals who are on social
media
and looking at how many people
those individuals follow and how many
people follow them and what they come up
with is a so-called social desirability
index they were able to correlate in a
very straightforward way that people
that carry certain variants in the
oxytocin and oxytocin receptor genes
actually seek out more online social
Instagram interactions so some people I
know I won't name their names only
follow you know anywhere from zero to
six accounts other people follow
thousands of accounts and they take the
ratio of how many accounts people follow
versus how many followers they have
arguably not a perfect measure but a
nice one in the sense that you can do
this in a completely unbiased way with
many many thousands of subjects and then
they were able to get genomic analysis
from a number of these subjects and it
turns out that people who have let's say
higher levels of oxytocin function or
potential
levels of oxytocin function actively
seek out more social interactions on
social media so this I think represents
an important first in the area of how
social media and data from social media
are starting to merge with biological
data
in terms of predicting how avidly people
will seek out social interactions of an
online type and nowadays we hear a lot
about how online we are connected but
we're not really where what is it we're
communicating but we're not connected or
the connections aren't real I think
we're going to need to revisit that
while I'm certainly a believer in the
idea that face-to-face communication and
common interactions with people
standing in the same space or playing
sports together enjoying music together
enjoying meals together is vitally
important there's an entire generation
or several generations of people that
are coming up who much of their social
interaction has been online and if you
think about it all the things that we've
spelled out earlier about common mental
narrative this left brain system Allah
Allen Shore or autonomic bonding or
synchronization of heartbeats according
to Common stories all that is happening
in online social interactions when a
thousand of us look at the exact same
Instagram post yes we will have a
thousand independent responses to that
but chances are many of us have a
similar or same response based on the
data that we talked about earlier in
synchronization of heartbeats and so we
are socially bonded with other people
through social media and it's very
apparent that the oxytocin system is
playing some role in that and this if we
zoom out makes perfect sense because
again
dopamine serotonin prolactin oxytocin
none of these systems were placed in us
or are organized within us in order to
encourage specific and only specific
types of social interactions the one
that we can say is absolutely critical
is the child parent interaction right
because children simply can't take care
of themselves they need a caretaker I
should have said caretaker not parent
but infants if they don't if they're not
taken care of will die but beyond that
we have evolved or come to realize many
different types of social interactions
and online interactions nowadays are
very very common I'm certainly involved
in them I'm guessing you're involved in
them as well we're involved in one right
now for example
the oxytocin system is absolutely
threaded through and largely responsible
for those types of social bonds as well
and incidentally oxytocin is the name of
the fifth song on Billy eilish's second
album happier than ever rule number
eight reduce caffeine and alcohol intake
violent aggression is entirely
appropriate at a professional boxing
match provided it's occurring inside the
ring and only between the competitors
and within the bounds of the rules of
the sport
Etc
however there are some things that tend
to bias certain social contexts toward
being more aggressive or less aggressive
and not always physical aggression and
those generally come in two forms that
many of you are familiar with which are
alcohol and caffeine
let's discuss caffeine first why would
caffeine increase aggressive impulsivity
well the general effects of caffeine are
to increase autonomic arousal the
activity of the so-called sympathetic
arm of the autonomic nervous system
which is
to put it very much in plain language
it's the alertness arm of your nervous
system that is it creates a sense of
Readiness in your brain and body and it
does so by activating the so-called
sympathetic chain ganglia again as I
always remind people simpa and
sympathetic does not mean sympathy Simba
means together or all at once and
caffeine tends to bias our brain and
body to activate the sympathetic chain
ganglia which run from about the base of
your neck until the top of your pelvis
and deploy a bunch of chemicals that jut
out into the rest of your body activate
adrenaline release there's a parallel
increase in of adrenaline in your brain
creating the state of alertness and
Readiness that state of alertness and
Readiness can be for all sorts of things
not just aggression however when we are
in a state of increased sympathetic tone
meaning more alert such as after
drinking caffeine we will bias all those
brain and body systems the hormones the
chemicals Etc that exist toward action
as opposed to inaction so put simply
caffeine can increase impulsivity no
surprise there
on the opposite end of things alcohol
tends to decrease
activity in the sympathetic arm or the
autonomic nervous system tends to make
us feel less alert now initially it can
create a state of alertness because of
its effects in inhibiting the forebrain
our forebrain prefrontal cortex in
particular
has what's called top-down inhibition it
exerts a inhibitory or a quieting effect
on some of the circuits of the
hypothalamus such as the ventromedial
hypothalamus the way to conceptualize
this is that your forebrain is able to
rationalize and think clearly and to
suppress behavior and to engage the
no-go Pathways telling you don't say
that mean thing don't do that violent
thing Etc alcohol initially tends to
increase our level of overall activity
by reducing inhibition not just in that
forebrain circuit but in other circuits
tends to make us more active we tend to
talk more than we normally would move
more than we normally would but very
shortly thereafter starts acting as a
sedative by way of reducing activity in
the forebrain
releasing some of the deeper brain
circuits that are involved in
impulsivity but also causing a somewhat
set of effect and then of course as
alcohol levels increase even further
people eventually will pass out blackout
Etc
so what we've got with alcohol and
caffeine is we've got two opposite ends
of the spectrum caffeine increasing
arousal and Readiness and the tendency
for impulsivity and alcohol also
increasing
impulsivity but through a different
mechanism rule number nine focus on
service I believe that you know tattoos
are I mean this has come as no surprise
or a literal expression of what we feel
on the inside and you know I and I'm not
recommending this kids don't do this I
started getting tattooed really young
how are you at 14 I got my first tattoo
no way we did them ourselves within your
first one please don't know please no
one do this India ink and a needle and
um we used to do these as really bad
they're called knickknack tattoos or we
kind of would do this at home don't do
it it's really bad you get bad
infections they're ugly they they
blur they bleed that it's not good
um yeah I started getting tattooed I
when I was a kid and growing up
skateboarding in the punk rock scene
there were these guys that um the town
where I lived they called themselves the
Yahtzee guys I don't know why I don't
know what that was about but they all
had full sleeves and they were super
nice guys and they were all into
skateboarding and you know and vehicles
and I just looked up to these guys I
thought like someday I want full sleeves
I yeah I've got full sleeves I'm
basically like neck to neck to wrists
you know chest pieces as well yeah but
yeah uh backs covered yeah nothing on my
legs nothing on my stomach ribs yeah the
tops of my tops of my shoulders and
um I got a big picture of Costello my
dog back there I've got a picture of his
paw back there I've got a picture of
another dog he used to have
um there's still some space for a few
things there's some things very personal
to me
um it's not the reason that you prefer
not to show them yeah you know I think
that there are a couple reasons I'll
just be clear as to why first of all
um when I show up to podcast it's the
same way I show up to lecture in the
classroom
and I swear on my life this is my
mindset and this is my Mantra when I do
it I'm there to teach it's not about me
it's about the student it's about the
people learning
I don't want it ever to be about me I
don't want the focus to be on me I mean
obviously I'm the voice and the person
talking but I really want people to
internalize the information and I do
think that the tattoos because they have
nothing to do with the information are a
distraction they're just a distraction I
I don't know it would sort of like be
wearing like a bright yellow shirt or
something it's not my style I prefer to
kind of make myself disappear as much as
I can and let the information come
forward that's you know even when I gave
scientific lectures which I still do of
course for my my professor job
I generally liked the room to be pretty
dark and I wanted the light to be on the
data on the slides I was happy to do the
voice but I want people thinking about
the data so podcasting is a little
different you come through as a voice
not we're on YouTube a voice in an image
but I really prefer that it not be about
me now there's a human element too and I
think things have changed a lot when I
was growing up tattoos were not accepted
there are many work environments where
if you have for instance where people
prefer that they're surgeon or their
doctor not have tattoos some people
might prefer their surgeon or doctor
have tattoos when I was growing up if
you had a uh I never had one but if
someone had a nose ring they had to
cover it up with a Band-Aid or take it
out if they worked at the coffee shop
remember that you probably don't you're
probably young enough no or eyebrow ring
think Trends have changed right things
have changed and I'm kind of old school
because I'm kind of old Now 46 and the
etiquette for me has always been to you
know and this is Lex does this too is I
I personally find that if I can just
show up as formal and consistent as
possible that people will at least know
that I'm taking them seriously so I
don't really do it for me I pretty much
do it for the audience
um and also none of the tattoos are like
that interesting or it's my dog I really
like Raptors I've got a bunch of birds
I've got I mean I have all sorts of
different things Raptors like the
dinosaur no Raptors like um red tail
hawks and blue you know I like birds I
had either dinosaurs or trucks yeah like
yo you really need to love Ford Raptors
no no Ford Raptor I drive a Toyota
4Runner and I love it I've got one truck
and I love that thing
um although with gas right now I mean
it's you kind of got to wonder about
having a gas driven vehicle like a
forerunner in any case yeah the tattoo
thing I would say for for younger people
coming up just be aware that you can't
control other people's perceptions
either and so you know I always made it
a point that I didn't want things on my
knuckles I didn't want them on my hands
I didn't want them on my neck I didn't
want them on my face do I judge people
when they have them no but do I want
them for me no I also think that this is
very neurosciency
as a neuroscientist that we have
dedicated brain areas called fusiform
gyrus it's a face area that's dedicated
to the processing of faces even if I
just put two dots and a line in between
them on a piece of paper you see that as
a face
when one puts a tattoo on their throat
or on their face it actually changes the
way that the face is perceived right I
mean it almost looks like another mouth
there right it's a very different look
it can be a little bit jarring I'm not
saying one shouldn't have it but it can
be a little bit jarring it's it changes
the look of the person forever it's not
just that it's above the neckline it's
that it kind of competes with the
processing of their face in its normal
way and so for me whenever I see
somebody with a throat tattoo or a face
tattoo sort of like it's hard to kind of
Orient around that and I think there's
some biology to uh to that relates to
that but look when it comes down to it I
mean people need to be individuals and
live their life the way they want to
live their life I've also never been
that much of an iconoclast I'm not you
know I'm I grew up in the punk rock
thing
um you know I hate in-group out group
stuff I always had friends from a lot of
different you know friends or jocks and
hippies and punk rockers and you know
straight and gay and like I don't care
as long as people are living in their
best life and they're not harming
anybody like I'm like great go for it I
I'm very laid back in that way of course
if people are harming other people then
I believe that like Liberty and
independent freedom I mean Liberty is
you know one of the highest things that
you know for me so
but I don't tend to I don't consider
myself a very judgmental person but you
can't always control the perceptions of
others so I would just think people
should be thoughtful about what they
want to accomplish in life in terms of a
life mission and just ask whether or not
some of the permanent cosmetic changes
they might make might might align with
compete with or be neutral for those
life missions my life mission is very
simple I want to teach people the Beauty
and the utility of biology I'm going to
do that today I'm going to do that until
I take my last breath in one form or
another because that's what excites me
and that's like what keeps the dopamine
cranking and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
prevent social isolation for better for
worse there is a tremendous literature
on the biology of social isolation and
all of the terrible things that happen
when animals or humans are socially
isolated at particular phases of life
now for those of you that are introverts
you are not necessarily damaging
Yourself by deciding to spend less time
with other people many people like time
alone I personally am an introvert I get
a thrill out of spending time with one
or two close friends but I enjoy a lot
of time by myself I like to socialize so
I wouldn't call myself an extreme
introvert but I know there's some
extreme introverts out there but when we
talk about social isolation what we're
referring to
is when animals are humans are
restricted from having the social
contacts that they would prefer to have
and to just briefly touch on the major
takeaways from this literature which
spans back 100 years or more
being socially isolated is stressful and
one of the Hallmark features of social
isolation is chronically elevated stress
hormones like adrenaline also called
epinephrine like cortisol a stress
hormone that at healthy levels is good
for combating inflammation helps us have
energy early in the day focused
throughout the day but if cortisol is
elevated for too long which is the
consequence of social isolation the
immune system suffers and other
chemicals start to be released in the
brain and body that are designed to
motivate the organism animal or human to
seek out social bonds
an example of one such chemical is a
peptide called tachykinen tachykinen is
present in flies in mice and in humans
and under conditions of social isolation
its levels go up and because of the
brain areas that contain receptors for
tachykinen people start feeling very
aggressive and irritable after social
isolation now that should be a little
bit counterintuitive to you you would
think oh you know if you isolate an
animal or human and then you give them
the opportunity for social interaction
they should behave very well they should
be thrilled they're finally getting the
nourishment the social nourishment that
they've been lacking for so long it
turns out that's not the case chronic
social isolation changes the nature of
the brain and body such that it makes
social connection harder and it makes
the person who's been isolated irritable
even aggressive with other people
now I don't want to go too deeply into
the biology of social isolation because
it doesn't actually afford US that much
insight into what healthy social bonding
looks like so today we're going to focus
more on the functional biology uh dual
meaning of the word functional as
opposed to the Pathology of social
isolation
however I do want to point out that
social isolation starts to deteriorate
certain aspects of brain and body pretty
quickly but how quickly depends again on
how introverted or extroverted somebody
is so if you're somebody who's socially
isolated for the holidays or has been
socially isolated for a period of time
and is craving social contact that is a
healthy craving and as we'll learn next
the healthy craving for social contact
has a very specific brain circuit has a
very specific neurochemical signature
associated with it and has some
remarkable features that you can
leverage in Social contacts of all kinds
I think some of the more important and
exciting work on social bonding comes
from the laboratory of K Thai K is a
professor at the Salk Institute for
biological studies she's an investigator
with the Howard Hughes Medical Institute
and in recent years I would say in about
the last five or six years her
laboratory has made a fundamental
discovery
as to why we seek out and put so much
effort into social bonds and the key
discovery that she made is that much
like hunger much like temperature much
like thirst
we have brain circuits that are devoted
to what's called a social homeostasis
many of you have probably heard about
homeostasis before homeostasis is the
characteristic of various biological
circuits and even individual cells to
try and maintain a certain level it's
most easily thought of in the context of
hunger if you don't eat for a while your
drive to pursue food and think about
food and make food and spend money on
food and indeed to enjoy food goes up
whereas when you're well fed you don't
tend to seek out food with as much Vigor
or as much intensity you wouldn't invest
as much time effort money Etc so
homeostasis is the aspect of cells
tissues and organisms to seek some sort
of balance to regulate themselves
in a crude way you can think about the
thermostat on your home as a homeostatic
circuit when the temperature goes up a
little bit it cools things down to
maintain a certain temperature when the
room gets cold it hits a certain level
and a sensor detects that it clicks on
and then the heat goes on to maintain a
certain set temperature so that's a
simple way of thinking about homeostasis
every homeostatic circuit has three
components or at least three one is a
detector meaning the organism or the
thermostat on your wall has to have some
way of detecting what's going on in the
environment all right in the context of
social bonding whether or not you are
interacting with others and whether or
not those interactions are going well so
that has to be detected that's the first
thing then there has to be a control
center that's the second thing and the
control center is the one that makes the
adjustments to in the case of social
bonding to your behavior and to your
psychology so you'll soon learn that
there are ways in which the more time
that you spend alone the more motivated
you are to seek out the pictures of
faces the interactions with actual
people physical contact and so forth now
that might seem obvious to you but
thanks to the work of ketai and others
it's remarkable to learn that there are
specific brain centers that are
adjusting our psychology and biology so
that we seek out bonds more aggressively
or maybe we don't because we are
perfectly sated or satiated with respect
to how much contact we've had with other
people
now the third component of this
homeostatic circuit is the effector the
effector is actually what drives the
behavioral response it what it's what
leads you to pick up your social media
and start scrolling it's what leads you
to text a friend it's what leads you to
call a friend or make plans and what
leads you to follow through on those
plans so again those three components
are a detector a Control Center and an
effector and as you'll soon learn the
neural circuit that controls the social
homeostasis actually has a fourth
component and that fourth component is
one that places subjective understanding
as to why you are doing what you are
doing and
establishes your place in a hierarchy
now in other word hierarchy can be a
little bit of a of a barbed wire one
because people immediately start
thinking about boss and subordinate or
in couples a leader and a follower but
when we talk about social hierarchies in
the context of human interactions social
hierarchies are very plastic meaning in
one setting one person can be the leader
in another setting the other person can
be the leader you probably have groups
of friends or family members where
you're constantly passing the the Baton
as to who's going to drive who's going
to navigate who's going to pick the
restaurant who's going to clear the
dishes and who's going to do certain
activities and not others so hierarchies
are very Dynamic and as a consequence
social bonding has to be very plastic
and very fluid so that you move from one
environment to the next even with the
same people you have to be able to make
those adjustments and in the case of the
social homeostasis circuit those
adjustments are made by a particular
brain structure I've talked about on
this podcast before it's called the
prefrontal cortex it is the seat of our
higher Consciousness if you will it's
what allows us to place subjective
labels on things so we are not strictly
input output we are not robotic meaning
if you go to dinner with a friend and
they are exceptional at choosing
restaurants well in the context of the
social homeostasis circuit your
prefrontal cortex would allow them to
pick the restaurant because basically
they are dominant over you in their
capacity to pick good restaurants at
least in this example whereas as you
leave that restaurant and perhaps you
are navigating to where to get a drink
after dinner or where to walk through
the city perhaps you have the better
sense of direction and so then the
social bonding has to be maintained as
you switch the hierarchy okay so that's
the role of that fourth element the
prefrontal cortex
Paul heard the sayings you know how do
you you know Journey Of A Thousand Miles
starts with a single step or how do you
eat an elephant one bite at a time or
you know they're all these sayings and
and you know goes back to the Bible and
earlier right I mean this is not new
these are not new sayings but they're
showing up in different forms
what's lost in those short descriptions
however is that every step is not
equivalent if it were just at a journey
of a Thousand Miles starts with a single
step everyone would pursue their goals
everyone would push back against
adversity everyone I mean you can read
the inspirational stories as many times
as one needs and I do think
inspirational stories are a very high
value in fact I think they're vicarious
dopamine I think they give us the sense
that we could which then Orient hope
which then orients us to the world to
start yeah I'm saying maybe it's
possible for me that's right so let's
say um let's take the example of
somebody who's
um because there's a thing is that's
that story of it's not about just taking
a single step and one step at a time
is it because there's adversities every
10 steps you go and so it's harder and
harder so it's not just well it's just
very non-linear you know it's it's some
days ago you know I know this from a
scientific career it's you know some
days it's easy some day is hard it's all
over the place right so I think the
thing to remember is that dopamine is
this incredibly powerful molecule that
allows us to buffer the effort process
it allows us to be an effort longer and
it allows us to actually eventually
enjoy the process of effort and not
think about the reward but just say oh
I'm enjoying the process right well you
just described the first step the first
step in learning to attach dopamine to
the effort process which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to be
very careful about how much you focus on
the end goal keeping the goal in mind is
important for like a proper orientation
you have to know the ultimate
destination but if at any point we were
to evaluate our progress relative to
that end goal or if we don't know what
the end goal is there's a huge gap there
and it can feel overwhelming and
depressing and I'm not good enough
that's right I should just give up what
am I doing this for that's right it's
thoughts will affect us and they're very
realistic right I mean as Carol will say
and other people have said in the
psychology field you know positive
self-talk oftentimes unless you do it
correctly you're badly wrong you know
lying to yourself won't work saying
saying I'm I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm
a winner or you haven't won yet is is
great but that's not the most effective
use of these systems well you're also
being out of Integrity with yourself
you're you're telling yourself a lie
right you're like and then you're losing
your ability to have confidence because
you you just lined yourself right and if
it's really extreme there's a name for
it it's called delusional right right
and people will start to point that out
and then it becomes harder to recruit
people into your your goals so I think
the key thing is to attach that sense of
reward to the effort process it's saying
look
I am oriented in the right direction and
rewarding the things you're not doing
I'm not back on my heels I'm not just
staying you know I'm better anymore yeah
a good example of this came to me
recently I have a good friend he did
nine years in the SEAL Teams his name is
Pat dossett and and we were talking
about you know the Admiral mccraven
thing you know get up and make your bed
and you know and they they really do
that and I think the way it was
described was
um you know so at the end of the day
even if everything doesn't go well your
bed is still made for me that's not that
big of a reward frankly right but I and
so I said that and I I love it though I
make my bad oh I definitely made my bed
in the morning but I mean going back and
seeing that at the end of a hard day
it's not enough I felt like there was
something else there so I asked him he
said well it's very interesting because
part of it is about not just making your
bed but it's the things you're not doing
by making your bed you're not lying in
bed and ruminating you're not back on
your heels and on your phone that's
right yeah when so when you look at and
you have spent a lot of time with people
in high performing communities
mainly through some Consulting work but
what you find is that you know we can
all be either be back on our heels
flat-footed or forward Center of mass
and when you look at people who are in
these high performance communities they
try and keep their Center of mass
forward
almost through what seemed like trivial
things like making your bed or making
the cup of coffee but it's not just
about what you're doing it's all the
things you're not doing interesting that
can put you down the path of ruminating
or put you down the path of
um unhealthy Behavior so the key to this
is if we want to be very concrete we
should probably focus on actions and
I'll use Fitness as an example because
it translates to everybody whereas you
know people's circumstance is different
let's say somebody really wants to take
on a fitness routine
they hate running or they want to lose
weight in a healthy way this kind of
thing so we've all heard the example
well you put your shoes by the door on
day one day two you put them on day
three you go out the door day four you
walk around the block and then you know
and then eventually like they're running
marathons okay great but to sustain that
behavior or even to make the the
behavior pleasureful and to give you
energy the key is to subjectively reward
those steps so it's not going to be
let's say I go out and I run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mile the hard part you want to
tell yourself this is the good part this
is the part that gives me energy and
I'll be very surprised if people don't
actually feel like they could continue
further so it's a journey of a Thousand
Miles starts with the single is made up
of you know single steps but the key is
to reward the harder steps not the
easier ones and not the ones where you
get the thing that you want don't reward
yourself for putting your shoes on and
taking a step outside you could if that
was a huge barrier for you it was very
hard it is very hard for you running the
10 miles that's hard find the wall
and push a little bit further through
that wall and reward that process so
this is why I think reps in the gym the
final reps like reps to failure
are usually not the best example first
of all most people aren't doing reps to
failure and it doesn't translate to
young kids and stuff where they probably
shouldn't be doing heavy reps to failure
this kind of thing what you want however
is if you're going to go there to think
about these are the this is the hard
part because that's when adrenaline
norepinephrine are getting maxed out and
that's when you have an opportunity to
bring dopamine in and teach those neural
Pathways to slam that back down and
I don't want to um highlight them too
much because they are a very Niche and
specialized Community but you look at
people in Special Operations you look at
the
um process like the whole evaluation
process of who gets in and who doesn't
it's really about putting people into
stress and seeing who can not just make
it through that stress but buffer that
stress reward the process through
teamwork reward the process of stress
through some internal dialogue that has
everything to do with not being back on
your heels not being flat footed but
Center of mass forward and I should also
be clear I'm not talking about everybody
being super aggro and always like you
know work work yeah in fact if you're
spending too much epinephrine if you're
too much of an adrenaline junkie you
will burn out eventually unless you can
find ways to recover yourself or to
buffer that with dopamine and the
recovery process is especially important
there's a second reward system so you've
got the dopamine system and I guess to
really put a box around it the
subjective reward needs to be done at
the hardest portion of a process the
tough conversation with a significant
other it's like when it's really tough
and you want you just that's when you
want to start telling yourself this is
the this is the good part because I'm
not speaking or this is because I think
right I'm not reacting or this is the
good part because I'm probably not doing
it correctly but I'm on the right path
right
um they're upset they're not feeling
your empathy you know this kind of thing
or you're not really understanding
what's going on you're getting
frustrated but if you tell yourself this
is this is the neural pathway getting
ground in there like it really dialed in
so that the the next time this I'm going
to Breeze right past this that's really
how the process works because dope
remember no one comes along and drips
dopamine in your ear even if you get a
billion dollars or you win a Nobel Prize
or you win the presidency it's all
internal these neurochemicals are all
internal and while some of them are
designed to be released in response to
things very reflexively like um you know
food sex sleep you know all these things
will trigger these neurochemicals we
have this big forebrain which allows us
to place subjective context on things
and whether or not that competition is
with you know
um mental material like books and
studying or whether or not it's physical
competition we need external influences
like I think we these days we're so
attracted to the idea that we can you
know control everything from the inside
but you need human interaction it's
absolutely necessary and I think that
um you know it sort of Harkens back to
the story at the beginning it's like all
the the stress and that I was going
through in those years I mean it
absolutely made me better right
absolutely maybe I wouldn't trade it for
anything I don't wish hardship on people
but humans are remarkable in their
ability to step into Challenge and to
meet challenge you know I think that
there's this important and very very
serious conversation now about mental
health right the number of people
suffering is just tremendous but I think
that we also are forgetting that you
know that suffering process is is it's a
jumping off point right and I've had a
number of friends commit suicide I
understand just how you know that's
that's a horrible tragedy and depression
is absolutely terrible but there's also
this question of you know sort of like
what is our expectation about our mood
right like we're so what do we really
what are we really trying to achieve
with our moods and so I always say you
know there are five things that embody
our whole existence it's like our
Sensations what we feel our emotions our
perceptions our thoughts and our actions
that's pretty much it and of all of
those the emotions are the most
mysterious it's like it's kind of a
combination of perception and thoughts
you know you can control your behavior
you can control your thoughts people
often forget this but your thoughts are
your choice right I'm not saying you can
suppress thoughts I think there's been a
lot of attention on trying to learn how
to suppress thinking I've never been
able to suppress thinking ever but what
I can do is introduce new thoughts
actually Stephen pressfield who wrote
The War of art
brilliant author and ex-military uh he
he really I think he said something like
you know he was like in his mid-40s
before where he had his first real
thought and what I like to think he was
referring to was the first time that he
realized that you could actually
introduce a thought that thoughts aren't
just all spontaneous so they can be
deliberate you know your Sensations you
can control by your environment and your
perceptions are largely about kind of
like what sends you you know your
thoughts about what you sense right but
your feelings I think we overvalue
feelings and here I'm going to come
across as you know kind of a hardened
male and about this I you know I would
place myself actually kind of on the
wide emotionality scale but I've learned
over the years that emotions are just
kind of a mishmash of perception and
thought I think we over we overvalue
their utility and this is just my
opinion I don't have any scientific data
to support it but I also don't even know
how you study emotions in the lab every
time I see a laboratory that claims they
study emotions they're studying Behavior
every time there's I you know people are
talking about fear and about courage
they're talking about a behavior that's
measured we don't know what these
animals feel you know the foggiest I
don't know what you feel right now I
barely understand what I feel right now
so I think that as a species we've been
and in terms of mental mental health
we've been over focused on feelings and
I think we need to think more carefully
about physiology the discovery of growth
mindset is worth thinking about so
Carol's Discovery was these kids that
for whatever reason you know like doing
math problems even though they knew they
couldn't get the answers right these
were sure fail problems so it's the same
kind of people that like doing puzzles
and these kids not surprisingly go on to
do phenomenally well in a number of
different areas of academic Pursuit you
know but what's interesting about growth
mindset is that it seems like there's
some attachment of the reward systems of
the brain so the action or the pursuit
of a goal not just achieving a goal and
when we step back and we look at what
that really entails at a neurochemical
level we have reward systems in the
brain they generally fall into two
categories they're the world systems
that make you feel really good with kind
of the here and now and everything
that's within the confines of your skin
and the things you already have you know
love of your dog love of your spouse
gratitude for all the things you happen
to have and and those are generally
governed by the release of molecules
like serotonin and oxytocin okay but
then there's another reward system which
is the one that drove a lot of human
evolution which is the dopamine reward
system now dopamine is a very
misunderstood molecule it's often talked
about only in the context of reward like
I'm going to work to this goal I'm going
to build my company I'm going to you
know get 10 years of press whatever it
is and you reach it and you get this
dopamine reward and indeed that's true
but what's often not discussed is that
dopamine is secreted enroute to rewards
while you pursue rewards now the ability
to tap into that system
to subjectively amplify that pathway of
reward in pursuit of goals is an
absolute Game Changer when it comes to
things like
anything challenging that of long
duration or uncertainty or getting
through this covered you know pandemic
situation the but the amazing thing is
remember the brain only does five things
and we get to decide which of those
Sensations and perceptions have
relevance and which ones don't or which
ones are attached to a goal and which
ones aren't so growth mindset in its
purest form is the attachment of these
reward systems to the effort process to
the friction process and not just to
obtaining a reward and just as a kind of
final point to that there's a very um
well-known body of literature and
Neuroscience at least among
neuroscientists that talks about
something called reward prediction error
and it says if you can dose the dopamine
subjectively as you go through the
pursuit of something and then have a lot
of dopamine when you reach that thing
it's very likely that you're going to
reinforce that circuit there will be
neural plasticity and that circuit will
become stronger so the next time you
will revisit those sets of behaviors the
opposite can happen too where you're in
real anticipation of something this is
gonna be great this is gonna be great
this is gonna be great and then you
reach that goal and it's kind of
underwhelming and that generally
triggers this this circuit that I
referred to earlier this kind of
disappointment or pro-depressive circuit
so dopamine
is involved in reward but it's also
involved in the pursuit of rewards and
so as you reach a milestone or as you
tell yourself I'm on the right track
this friction I'm feeling this late
night this early morning this hard
conversation with somebody that doesn't
feel good I'm gonna tell myself this is
for a larger purpose that's that
subjective insertion that abstraction
that we were talking about earlier and
when you start releasing dopamine to
those kinds of things there's
essentially no limit on the number of
things you can do or the energy to do
them so just as a last last point about
dopamine when we're in effort we're
always secreting adrenaline we're always
in Pursuit and it's draining it's tiring
dopamine has this beautiful capacity to
buffer adrenaline and you know this
you've experienced this before because
if you've ever been working really
really hard maybe your team has depleted
everything's just a mess and somebody
cracks a joke and all of a sudden in an
instant it's like everything's reframed
that couldn't have been hormonal
hormones work on that on the schedule of
like hours to days to weeks it had to be
neurochemical it absolutely had to be
neurochemical and that neurochemical is
dopamine both those things breathing and
vision also run in Reverse meaning if we
change our pattern of breathing we
change our inner state
if our state changes our breathing
changes so it's reciprocal it's
bi-directional likewise with vision when
we are excited or stressed the aperture
of our visual window shrinks we get that
soda straw view of the world when we are
relaxed the aperture of our vision
expands but as well it runs in both
directions if we expand our view of the
world literally Force our our visual
field or just it's very easy actually
you can do it no matter where you are
right now if you just try and expand
your visual field not by looking around
or moving your head or eyes but by
trying to see yourself in the
environment that you're in so you
literally dilate your views you could
see the ceiling and the floor and the
walls if you're inside or if you're
Outdoors seeing as big an aperture of
your visual field or your visual
environment as possible so you're
directing your attention to even though
you might remain looking straight ahead
you're just directing your attention to
as wide a peripheral view horizontally
and vertically as possible is that what
you mean that's right exactly so
essentially if you keep your head and
eyes mostly stationary you don't have to
be you know rigid about rock steady but
if you look forward and you expand your
field of view so you kind of relax your
eyes so that you can see as much of your
environment around you as possible to
the point where you can see yourself in
that environment what you do is you are
turning off the attentional and believe
it or not the stress mechanisms that
drive your internal State towards stress
this is why when you go to a a Vista or
you view a horizon it's very relaxing
because you naturally go into panoramic
vision
when you are indoors you're looking at
your phone you're looking at a computer
or a camera or something of that sort or
you're talking to somebody or an intense
conversation you may not notice it but
your entire visual field shrinks to a
much smaller aperture and that drives an
increase in alertness in internal State
and we sometimes call that stress if
it's a negative experience if it's a
positive experience we might call that
love or Obsession or Fascination but the
important thing to realize is that both
vision and breathing
have a profound and very rapid effect on
our internal State of Mind and Body and
it runs in both directions
our internal state that could be
triggered by a text message or hearing
something that somebody says tries
changes in our breathing and our vision
but our breathing and our vision can
also Drive changes in our internal State
and so that article in Scientific
American was a discussion about how we
can leverage the visual system and the
respiration the breathing system in
order to take control over our internal
State because
it's not just that 2020 was stressful
it's that our internal State determines
everything it doesn't just determine if
we feel like we're having a hard time
falling asleep or we're having a hard
time focusing for instance it also
determines how we batch time how we
analyze where we are in the world in
terms of our lifespan a good example
this would be when we are very stressed
we find sliced time this is why when
people are in a car accident or
something they might report that things
were in slow motion they're actually
your frame rate increases whereas when
you're very relaxed your frame rate
slows down and when we are relaxed we
get so-called perspective
we are able to say well this too shall
pass or I can place the stressful event
in a context so one thing that's just
fundamental to how our nervous system
works is that we are constantly placing
our experience both our immediate and
past experience as well as our
anticipation of the future into some
sort of larger context and our visual
system literally how we are viewing the
world at that moment dictates how we
create perspective in terms of states of
Mind sounds a little bit abstract but
it's actually it boils right down to
Optics of the eye and very concrete
things like how you move your eyes and
how you view the world in fact there's a
much better way to maintain ongoing
action toward a goal that also involves
visualization but it turns out it's not
about visualizing success it's about
visualizing failure the balcattis lab
and other labs have looked at whether or
not people make progress toward goals of
different types whether or not they're
thinking about the goal they're thinking
about that goal line and what they want
to achieve that long-term goal and all
the wonderful things associated with it
or whether or not they're thinking about
all the ways in which they could fail
and root to that goal right this is not
typically what we are encouraged to do
typically we are told don't imagine
failure push failure out of your mind
only focus on success you know fake it
till you make it or it's a phrase that I
absolutely hate uh frankly because it's
not even clear what that means and it's
not even clear what the ethical form of
that is I think it means continue
despite any anxiety or fear that things
won't work out but if you look at the
literature the scientific literature
what the balcattus lab and other labs
have shown is that there's a near
doubling near doubling the probability
of reaching one's goal if you focus
routinely on
foreshadowing failure you think about
the ways in which things could fail if
you take action a or you take action B
and instead therefore you take action C
you're supposed to think about how
things could fail if you don't get up
and run each morning if your goal is say
a fitness goal so let's use that as an
example because even though I realize
people are in pursuit of many things not
just Fitness
fitness goals and physical goals are a
very concrete thing that we can all get
on the same page about
because they're related to actions let's
say somebody that sets a goal of running
five miles four times a week minimum and
as many as seven four times a minimum
before eight a.m okay in a previous
podcast on habits I talked about the
benefits of non-necessarily setting
specific times that one will do things
but setting time blocks that one will do
things you say before 8 AM you're gonna
run five miles and that's gonna happen
up to seven days a week okay
one version of this would be okay sit
back in a chair and think about how
great you're gonna feel and look if
you're doing this every day how your
health is going to improve how
everything's going to your blood markers
of lipids Etc are going to improve okay
fine that's the visualization goal of
visualizing the end point turns out that
is far less effective and maybe even
counterproductive compared to thinking
about what's going to happen if you
don't do this the negative Health
outcomes that are going to occur the
disappointment you're going to have in
yourself the fact that you're going to
wait until 7 30 that's not long enough
for many people to run 5 miles you go to
put it on your shoes it could be pouring
rain or even hailing or snowing outside
and now you're not going outside unless
you're somebody who's particularly
motivated to do that okay so
foreshadowing failure turns out to be
the best way to motivate toward goal
pursuit in fact as I mentioned before
there's a near doubling in the
likelihood that people will reach goals
of any kind when they're constantly
thinking about how bad it's going to be
if they fail if we think back to the
neural circuit associated with assessing
value in our goal Pursuits this makes
perfect sense the amygdala that center
of the brain that's involved in anxiety
and fear and worry well the amygdala is
one of the four core components of our
goal setting and goal Pursuit circuitry
and there's no bypassing that there is
no one listening to this or watching
this whose amygdala is not involved in
their goal setting and goal Pursuit
behavior and so while I'd love to be
able to tell you that all you should
think about is rainbows and puppies and
all the wonderful rewarding things that
are going to happen when you achieve
your goals
the truth is you should be thinking
mainly about how bad it's really going
to get if you don't do it how
disappointing yourself you're going to
feel how
it will negatively impact you if not in
the immediate term in the long term if
indeed your goal is to reach your goal
so I want to emphasize that I'm not
interested in encouraging people to
flagellate themselves I'm encouraging
people to
achieve their goals and it turns out the
best way to do that is by foreshadowing
failure and the more specific you can
get by writing down or thinking about or
talking about how bad it will be if you
don't achieve your goals the more likely
you are to achieve those goals I really
believe that we all have some superpower
that reflects maybe this is a bit of a
scientific explanation that reflects the
fact that our biology
tilted in some Direction people often
thinks about their biology being tilted
in a direction that doesn't serve them
like oh you know my parents were this
and my you know or I'm not a good
athlete or um whatever but
it's also tilted in the direction of
something really special so like when I
was a kid
of that age I was fascinated by animals
I was just like my and so
had I learned to listen to that more I
used to hide my interest in animals
because I thought it was kind of not it
wasn't cool like I didn't play the
guitar in college I didn't surf I always
like like I can tell you all these facts
about mustelids and ferrets like what
good is that but like you know but I
think that kind of leaning that kind of
tilt towards like huh like that's me
like you resonate with something and I'm
not the first to say this I think Robert
Greene also said this like there's a
adults will often remember back to a
time where they interacted with
something sometimes it's an object or
sometimes it's an experience and it just
felt so good like it it kind of Drew you
in I would tell your young listeners to
and viewers to really
pay attention to that it can seem almost
trivial like it's rarely about the thing
you're looking at or the thing you're
doing but sometimes it's the sensation
of running sometimes it's it's it's the
sensation of viewing seeing something or
hearing something because there's a hint
there and it's that it's not really
about what you're looking at or you're
doing it's that feeling like learn it
that feeling is your compass like that's
your true north because that's the
feeling you want to get to for to find
you know the mate for your life the you
know the partner for your life the the
career track and over time you're gonna
pivot right I mean you're not gonna get
it on the first try I eventually my
story of science started there it told
me right there I I felt it in that
conversation with my dad and then my
compass was all over the place and
spinning and eventually it's it's come
back I found it but getting in get in
touch with that feeling and if this
seems at all abstract I would do it as
an experiment
I would sit in a chair and I would think
about something you don't like
me like really don't like and I would
pay attention to what that feels like in
your mind and in your body I'm not a
very somatic person I'm not somebody who
like feels stuff at the level of the
body I've always felt like my emotions
were my head so when people talk like
their emotions and their other places
I'm just like I'm like I don't get it
but I would encourage them to think
about that and then I would encourage
them to think about something they
really like
that could be roller coasters could be
music could be get specific and to get
in touch with that feeling and that
feeling is your guide that feeling is
your compass because the nervous system
it's not mystical the nervous system
will Orient toward the things that it's
best equipped to do
it really will
and I really animals do this naturally
my Bulldog Costello never tries to be a
different kind of dog he never fetched
once first time I threw the ball he
walked to the ball he sat down with the
ball he destroyed the ball because
that's what Bulldogs do
you know throw to a retriever they bring
it back because the brain of the
retriever is wired to feel good by
retrieving and the brain of the Bulldog
is good to feel good by being horizontal
with and pulling on things with their
they like to tug so I think humans we're
so we're similar enough but we're
different in the sense that you have
something installed in you that feels
right and getting in touch with that
feeling is key and you're not and I
should tell that there's no you're not
going to get it right away this is a
practice you learn like shooting
basketballs or or math you do it over
and over so that but if you get started
young at eight or nine oh my goodness
great and if you do it when you're 12 or
even if you're 60 and you do this you'll
find that pretty soon you start steering
in these directions and I I do believe
it's a nervous I think our it's a neural
there's a real physical substrate for
this I it's not mysticism I'm never
gonna argue that we can subjectively
control all of our experience because
there's some things that just genuinely
suck right and when they and it's
important and it's important to register
those those not so great events or
terrible events because they can drive
us also you know we can be driven from a
place of anger for frustration and you
know Revenge we can be driven from a
place of you know love gratitude and Etc
I'm not here to judge which one is
better or worse but the nervous system
doesn't distinguish between them so if
you're the kind of person that needs to
you know kind of budge yourself into
something great if you're the kind of
person that wants to do things from more
of a warm fuzzy feeling that's fine too
what I will say is this the ability to
tap into this dopamine reward system
which is activated anytime you're in
pursuit of something that's outside the
boundaries of your skin and literally
the boundaries of your body as well as
the reward system the serotonin oxytocin
system which is really about the things
that are contained within your own body
and immediate experience things like
gratitude and you know touch and comfort
and things like that with loved ones the
ability to tap into both is crucial now
you said something really important
which was well negative thoughts
negative thoughts what to do I don't
believe that it's very easy to suppress
negative thoughts however when you
realize that thoughts can be
deliberately introduced you can start
replacing negative thoughts with new
types of thoughts so you can always add
something in but when people start to
realize that thoughts are very much like
physical actions of reaching and picking
up a glass of water or taking a jog
around the ball block or typing an email
perfectly this is something I sometimes
do because I'm I you know I struggle to
do the perfect email not all my emails
are perfect but when I do one I make
sure that I I complete and I think okay
it's possible it's not because the email
being perfect is so important it's
because I want to remind myself that my
thoughts and my actions are essentially
the same the nervous system can organize
thoughts so for somebody that's
struggling
you know we have these examples like oh
they were really back on their heels or
they were so depleted no money and all
this stuff what are they gonna we we
have so many examples like that but in
trying to make it actionable it's really
about saying yep that's all true but I'm
going to introduce a thought which is I
made it through today I'm I made it
through today and that's actually worth
celebrating at a micro level so if you
can give yourself dopamine rewards in
small increments right you're not trying
to celebrate that you made it through
one day sometimes that's a huge feat but
most of the time you just want to dose
yourself with a little bit of that
internal release of dopamine you start
rewarding incremental steps and if
there's anything that your listeners
could take away from this whole thing
about dopamine and reward schedules and
being in movement it's reward
incremental steps in particular
incremental steps that are about forward
action so maybe that's writing an email
maybe that's
um maybe that's that run around the
block maybe that's something much
grander for you as you get better at
things right the stairs get further and
further away from one another because
you've achieved more success and so they
tend to be you have to take the rungs on
the ladder further apart so to speak
that's a time when you really need to
implement not only the dopamine rewards
but also those serotonin and oxytocin
rewards Etc so to make it actionable I
would say remember don't spend so much
time trying to suppress negative
thoughts if you need trauma therapy
pursue that with a professional but if
you have negative thoughts just remember
I can also introduce positive thoughts
the same way I can control running
around the block positive thoughts are
the equivalent of forward physical
action and if you reward them internally
you buffer yourself against the quitting
circuit this norepinephrine circuit we
were talking about before you are
building a stronger version of yourself
completely between your own ears and
some people say well that's silly it's
like you're saying oh I'm going to jump
up and down reward myself for doing
nothing no you're building the neural
circuits that reward that you can
control self-reward and in doing that
you can push through days and weeks of
effort consistently I don't mean
necessarily all-nighters but you can
push and push and push growth mindset
which is the academic Discovery and
laboratory discovery of my colleague
Carol dweck at Stanford is the Hallmark
of growth mindset is really two things
one is I'm not where I want to be now
but I but I will I'm capable of getting
there eventually the other is to attach
a sense of reward to the effort process
itself in fact don't reward the resolve
reward the effort that's right and if
you look at true High performers people
that are consistently good at what they
do they don't peek and go through the
postpartum depression and crash and come
back and their life is a cycle of ups
and downs but really people who are on
that upward trajectory consistently
those people attach dopamine to the
effort process and actually Carol's one
of her original studies on the discovery
of growth mindset was these kids that
love doing math problems that they knew
they couldn't get right
so it's like the people love puzzles but
in this case they knew they couldn't get
it right but they loved doing it and it
incidentally or not so instantly these
kids are fantastic at math when there is
a right answer because they they feel
some sense of reward from the effort
process yeah now the cool thing about
dopamine
is that it's very subjectively
controlled we can all learn to secrete
dopamine in our brain in response to
things that are in a purely subjective
way our interpretation our
interpretation and but it has to be
attached to reality so you know one
should never confuse what is real right
so no so if you're if you're thinking
about the effort you're expending so
let's say somebody right now is
financially back on their heels and
they're setting up a new business for
instance and it's hard
if they can take a few moments or
minutes each day to reflect on the fact
that the effort process is allowing them
to climb out of their hole potentially
that it's giving them an opportunity
that it's
somehow
they are on the right path or if they're
not in movement along that path or at
least oriented on the right path they're
not lying in bed all day they're taking
a step if they can reward that process
internally two things happen
first of all the brain circuits that are
associated with building subjective
rewards and dopamine gets stronger so
you get better at that process and
second and most importantly dopamine has
an amazing ability to buffer adrenaline
and buffer epinephrine and what I mean
by that is there was a study that was
published in the journal cell excellent
Journal cell Press Journal a couple
years ago showing that with repeated
bouts of effort we use and we release
more and more epinephrine it's kind of
adrenaline but in the brain
with more effort every time every time
you put in effort so every time you make
look for this let's keep it if I were to
keep it in the business context every
time you make write that email every
time you let's say it's a person who's a
Craftsman and a crafts woman every time
you're working in the in the shop and
doing that every bit of effort
you're
taking a little bit of money out of this
epinephrine account you're spending
epinephrine at some point
those levels of epinephrine get high
enough that you you feel like quitting
it feels exhaustive and this was done in
a beautiful study actually where
um they control the visual environments
and they have the subjects EX exert
effort and they can control the visual
environment so sometimes the effort of
of taking steps and moving forward is
actually kind of pushing forward and
kind of swimming motion
um would give them the Sensation that
they were actually making progress and
other times it was an exercise in
futility where they would just keep the
the visual World stationary and they
would expend effort and they didn't
think they were going anywhere
epinephrine's climbing climbing climbing
and eventually they quit now dopamine is
able to push back on that epinephrine
and give you
anyone the the feeling that you could
continue and maybe even the feeling that
you want to continue and you've seen
this actually like football is a good
example two teams play say the Super
Bowl both teams are Max effort the
entire time yeah Max effort
the team that wins suddenly in a moment
has the energy to jump all over the
place party for days they can talk I
mean
right before that well that wasn't
glycogen or stored energy of any kind
except it was neural energy and what
happened was effort is this adrenaline
adrenaline adrenaline adrenaline
eventually people quit they just quit
the
dopamine is able to suppress that and so
then you're expending effort but you're
doing it from a place of feeling like
you have energy for it for any of us
success in any Endeavor is very closely
related to how much Focus we can bring
to that endeavor
and the reward system you start to
realize is entirely internal no one's
coming along and cramming dopamine in
your ear or dripping it in your brain
it's all internal and this starts to
bring us into the kind of like
discussion around mindsets because so my
colleague Carol dweck who you know
popularized the same growth mindset it's
again a very misunderstood concept it's
the idea that we can change so that's
built into that but the discovery of
growth mindset was of these kids that
actually really enjoyed doing problem
sets that they knew they couldn't get
right but for them they would get this
like dopamine release from just focusing
on the problem they like doing puzzles
they couldn't get right it sounds crazy
but inevitably those kids are very good
at puzzles and very good at math and
these kinds of things so growth mindset
is I believe it was sort of a neuro
Neuroscience lens on growth mindset
would be that the agitation and stress
that you feel at the beginning of
something and when you're trying to lean
into it you can't focus is just a
recognized gate you have to pass that
through that gate to get to the folk
component and then if you can reward the
effort process you really start to feel
Joy on low levels of excitement in the
effort process that's that buffering of
adrenaline that's that feeling like yes
I've got a lot of adrenaline in my
system but I'm on the right path it
feels good to walk up this hill so to
speak and when you start to bring those
neural circuits together
you really start to create a whole set
of circuits that are designed to be
exported to any Behavior you want
so if it's writing a book great if it's
podcasting great if it's building a
business great if it's if it's you know
building a terrific relationship great
then the circuits that Mother Nature's
design are incredibly generic so that we
could adapt to whatever it is that we
need to do and I think the
misunderstanding around how these
circuits work has led to this idea that
there's some secret entry point maybe
marked flow on the door and there's a
trampoline up to that door and you just
open that door and you're going to be in
it right and nothing could be further
from the truth and anyone who's done
well in any career or athletic Pursuit
knows this but unfortunately there's a
kind of obsession with the idea that
it's all supposed to feel good and it
does feel good but there's a whole
staircase in which it feels kind of
lousy to what extent does our subjective
narrative the story the story We Tell
ourselves actually means something for
the body and to what extent does the
body actually mean something for the
subjective narrative so this gets into
some Mary areas of work that we're doing
now and so I do want to highlight that
it's ongoing work but I think you know
the old narrative meaning a few 10 years
ago was that if you're feeling depressed
just smile well if that worked right we
would have a lot less depression than we
see out right the reason I call it a
brain body contract early on is that
their the brain and the body are
constantly in dialogue so you know the
idea that when we're depressed we tend
to be in more defensive type postures
when we're feeling good we tend to be in
more like relaxed and extended postures
all true
but it does not mean that just by
occupying the extended posture that I'm
going to completely shift the mind right
that's a first step think about like two
interlocking gears it's one gear that
turns the other but then they need to
kind of dance together before you can
get the whole system going that's how
you get it to dance together exactly so
subjective there is one way in which
subjective thought and deliberate
thought is very powerful Over States of
mind and body to answer your question
can you think your way out of the ice
bath being cold so a couple things that
are important first of all just to go a
little deeper on what thoughts are
thoughts happen spontaneously all the
time they're popping up like a poorly
filtered internet connection
but thoughts can also be deliberately
introduced for instance right now I can
say okay have a thought that just decide
to write your name and you're you can do
that I'm going to decide to write on him
and you can do it so that's a deliberate
thought which says that you can
introduce thoughts so I think it's very
hard to control negative thoughts
directly by trying to suppress them
generally they tend to just want to
continue to geyser up all the time but
we can introduce a positive thought this
is what people from elite special forces
can do they know how to make small
simple
physical steps in the real world that
allow them to build on these reward
circuitries but they don't get
delusional about how they're doing they
they know they keep the end in mind but
they get very micro they move the
Horizon in very close and so if you can
move the Horizon to something you know
you can complete and you reward that you
essentially are where you were before
you're just as strong if not stronger
but you're heading in the direction you
need to go you're not depleting you're
not spending out anything and it feels a
little weird because none of us like to
reward things that aren't external but
the ability to control these internal
reward schedules is everything an
ability to control your levels of stress
in real time is extremely powerful
it turns out you can do this using
physiology and Neuroscience
your breathing can directly impact your
heart rate and your level of stress or
calm here's how it works
when you inhale your diaphragm moves
down this creates more space in your
thoracic cavity and your heart actually
gets a little bit bigger as a
consequence the rate of blood flow
through that larger heart volume
slows down
signal is sent from a group of neurons
on your heart called the sinoatrial node
that signal goes up to the brain and
your brain sends a signal to speed the
heart up in other words inhaling speed
your heart rate up
the opposite is true as well when you
exhale your diaphragm moves up
your heart gets a little bit smaller
because there's a little bit less space
in your thoracic cavity
as a consequence blood flows more
quickly through that smaller volume the
sinoatrial node registers that and sends
a signal to your brain and the Brain
sends a signal to slow the heart down so
in other words inhaling speeds your
heart rate up exhaling slows your heart
rate down so if you want to speed up
your heart rate and be more alert
inhale more or make those inhales more
vigorous more intense if you want to
calm down you can do that quickly by
making your exhale slightly longer than
your inhales or making them more
vigorous this doesn't require any breath
work this is something that you can do
in real time and that's what's called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia that's the
technical phrase It's also the basis of
what's called heart rate variability or
HRV but all you need to remember is
inhaling deeper and longer will speed
your heart rate up exhaling longer and
more intensely will slow your heart rate
down and will allow you to calm down in
real time
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from David Sinclair
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there and it turns out
that the only ones that live longer are
the ones that only ate once a day and so
that if we're we're not mice but I think
that we're close enough to mice that it
tells us a lot but I still think the
best bang for the longevity Buck is to
do both well eat less